[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
débrief des questions au gouvernement
pour cette séance qui a été plutôt calme
il faut le dire peut-être tout
simplement parce qu'elle était organisée
exceptionnellement un jeudi et que du
coup l'hémicycle était loin d'être plein
et puis séance calme peut-être tout
simplement en raison de ce rappel à
l'ordre qui a été adressé en début de
séance par le président de l'assemblée
en personne richard ferrand
j'ai reçu à l'issue de notre précédente
séance de questions au gouvernement de
nombreux messages d'émotion face au
tumulte qui perturbe parfois le
déroulement des séances de questions au
gouvernement
ceci affecte gravement l'image de notre
assemblée je vous invite donc
solennellement à écouter les orateurs en
vous abstenant de tout exclamations ou
interpellation bruyante
voilà pour ce rappel à l'ordre séance
calme je vous le disais mais séance
utile malgré tout puisqu'elle a permis
d'apporter des précisions sur plusieurs
annonces faites par emmanuel macron le
14 juillet
première précision tout d'abord sur le
port du masque obligatoire dans les
lieux publics faut-il vraiment attendre
la date du 1er août
question posée par le député les
républicains jean pierre door
regardez la réponse d'olivier ferrand
sur ce sujet du port du masque
systématiser voir demain et demain
obligatoire dans les lieux clos et bien
il ya un décret qui est en cours de
finalisation monsieur le député d'ici à
lundi ou mardi
le port du masque devra être généralisé
mais vous savez monsieur le député avant
même un décret la vigilance l'esprit de
responsabilité et de citoyenneté les
français ils ne nécessitent pas de
décret jouant courage et j'invite
l'ensemble des français a sans délai
sans attendre la parution d'un décret et
sans que l'obligation sata street dans
le marbre à porter un masque dans tous
les lieux clos enfin monsieur le député
s'agissant des tests nous allons
atteindre la barre des 400 mille tests
nous sommes capables d'en faire bien
davantage et même un million par semaine
s'il le fallait
et oui messieurs les députés et
laboratoires sont aptes à le faire
maintenant nous invitons les français
qui hésitent à se faire tester à le
faire et le présent la république
autre précision apportée lors de cette
séance elle concerne la taxe
d'habitation qui est encore payé par 20%
des français emmanuel macron à a
sous-entendu que la suppression de cette
taxe pourrait être reporté qu'en est il
exactement et bien c'est ce qu'a voulu
savoir la députée est leur constance le
grip
le chef de l'état dans son interview
télévisée du 14 juillet a évoqué comme
une option possible
l'idée de décaler un peu je reprends ses
propres termes pour les plus fortunés
la suppression de la taxe d'habitation
quand il dit les plus fortunés le
présent macron pas des 20% de français
qui payent encore la taxe d'habitation
c'est à dire ceux des français qui ont
des revenus supérieurs à 2500 euros par
mois autant dire les classes moyennes
sortez de l'ambiguïté et dites-nous
quand la taxe d'habitation sera supprimé
pour l'ensemble des français
je me réjouis d'entendre ce plaidoyer
flamboyant pour la suppression de la
taxe d'habitation
il est peut-être question peut-être
question peut-être pour certains des 20%
des français de légèrement repoussé
cette baisse d'impôts mais je veux vous
rassurer aussi les 5 milliards d'impôts
sur le revenu des personnes physiques
que nous avons supprimé cette année et
qui touche les classes populaires qui
travaillent les classes moyennes qui
travaillent
celle-là c'est 5 milliards de là ils
seront bien diminué cette année
voilà c'est tout pour ce débrief des
questions au gouvernement on se retrouve
la semaine prochaine
[Musique]